hello everybody and welcome to the
second practical flash tutorial video in
this video we're going to be just
continuing continuing along building our
website so now that we've done sudo
apt-get upgrade
luckily I'm pretty quick here and I'm
still connected but you'll find that
after a pretty short period of time of
inactivity you were going to lose
connection it's going to disconnect you
and it's kind of like a tie basically is
a timeout and so it's a security measure
where if you're inactive for X amount of
time it just disconnects and that's a
good idea but it can get annoying
sometimes now because I'm filming a
tutorial on it it's conceivable that I
talked for so many seconds and then all
of a sudden that were disconnected it's
very annoying sometimes or you're not
sure how to do something so you go to
Google you look it up and you come back
and you're disconnected it's a good idea
on your for sure on your development
server not necessarily a big deal on a
you know I mean it's a good idea for
sure on your production server I'm not
really sure it's a that necessary on a
development server again though is a
security kind of thing in place so
change at your own risk
but that's we're going to talk about now
and what better time to discuss how
developers develop in reality than this
this is the number one developer tool
I'm about to show you it's not really a
secret but kind of and that is this tool
right here sorry this is what developers
use honestly so my curiosity let's say
is I'm not sure how to stop this dang
timeout so let's say um let's say SSH
timeout Linux and look at that first
option I've already clicked it but
that's it SSH timeout Linux how to
disable it so we'll click on that link
and we're like okay what do we do we're
seeing a bunch of this nastiness
basically we're looking for some sort of
command line stuff and in the file so
generally you've got a configuration
file looks like we just found it so
we're going to look for SSH config
but you're going to learn that there's a
couple of different kind of meanings of
things depending on the operating system
so first let's get let's go to that
directory so that directory was let's do
CD etc' SSH let's just go there first
and then so CD for change directory and
then you give the full path directory
that you want to go to and let's do LS
and this lists out the stuff in here so
we see we do have an SSH config and we
also have an SH HD config and someone
can correct me I believe the ds4 daemon
but I might be wrong anyway uh so now to
open it we're going to use sudo for
Super User do and then Nano and then
I'll will first open up SSH config since
that's what the internet says so we come
in here and we're kind of looking around
and it doesn't look like there's really
much here in this file and if we kind of
look here as far as they're setting
suggestions let's say alive or keep
alive is the one I usually use to find
so to find something within a file in
nano control W and then let's say we
search for keep alive and it says keep
alive not found it's just not here so
this might not be the file we want let's
check out sshd config instead so sudo
nano if you want to like basically
rewrite the previous line you hit the up
arrow instead of SSH config will do sshd
config now again ctrl W keep alive and
little behold there it is so what was
the stuff that it was suggesting again
we'll come back to the lovely internet
here basically this line here so we've
got some stuff here that maybe we don't
understand but we can clearly see this
9999 that's probs what what we're
thinking is going to be you know this
really long-winded you know over 9,000
number so we'll copy that and we see at
least one of these TCP keepalive is
already here so we'll come here and a
way you can delete a whole line in Nano
is ctrl K boom done now after you've
copied something to paste you just right
click and bam there it is and then just
kind of watch out because you see this
little comment here it shouldn't make
any
any problem because it is a comment but
if it wasn't a comment it would cause
some trouble but anyway we'll hit enter
done now we want to save and exit so
ctrl X will exit it's asking if we want
to save it Y for yes this is the file
name as long as you want to save it the
same file name enter done so now we have
in theory a very long time out but of
course we need to actually since this
was we modified the SSH service so now
we need to restart that service so
service SSH restart done and that's it
so now we have this kind of unlimited
login and a brief introduction to the
number one developer tool moving along
we're ready to kind of set up this
website now so coming back over here
this is another developer tool and
honestly when I develop stuff I'll and
almost every developer I know they tend
to go back to their previous work and
like reference their previous work to
move forward so generally you hear about
people say they've got a cookbook right
that's their own private stash of code
that they've used to do all kinds of
stuff my cookbook just so happens to be
online and in tutorial form a lot of
times on Python programming net but
we're going to use one of them right now
so we're going to come over to web dev
and we're interested in the second one
right here so that's all this code that
we're about to run now but just in case
there wasn't one there let's go back
instead of SSH timeout let's say a
deploy flask Linux okay and we have a
couple of options here we've got the
flask mega tutorial from Miguel here but
then there's also this how to deploy a
flask application on Ubuntu VPS well
that sounds a lot like us let's click on
that bad boy and see what they have to
offer so they've got some stuff here and
then wouldn't you know it here's a bunch
of command line options for setting up
exactly what we want to do and so again
perfect and it's basically a bunch of
copy and paste you just copy and paste
all these little commands here and
change this R you'll probably wind up
with servers or the shot we're gonna use
here it's basically the same thing I
have changed a few things we're going to
at least start off with a few different
installation
hands a couple of tweaks here and there
but for the most part it's almost
identical to this one so again if you
weren't sure how to do it just google it
honestly the best resource you'll ever
find so anyway we're going to come here
and we're going to begin so we're just
going to start running all these
commands so first we've got this sudo
apt-get install Apache and in fact let
me do this just so you guys can see
exactly what I'm doing I hate to like go
back and forth and I hate to just not
show so that someone gets like lost but
you could probably run through these all
on your own anyway but anyway let's just
do this windows ok so first we're going
to get this and I'll explain kind of
what these are we've got apache for
running servers my sequel's for the
database we want both my sequel client
and the server I did want to continue
yes and that's going to go through and
then we're going to get this other thing
here well wait I guess for this oh we're
going to set up the my sequel root user
not to be confused with the root user of
your server so you're if you're using
the root user of your server that's
different than the root user of the my
sequel server ok you can make the
password the same if you want probably
not the best idea though so keep that in
mind so anyway I'm going to set this
password I'm gonna set it again done ok
don't forget that password by the way so
that's my sequel that's what the
database that we're going to be using
there's also SQLite I don't really feel
I it's great for kind of local versions
or a really light versions of a database
but I don't really think it makes a good
production database so what's the point
in using it in development
I was taking a lot longer ice with it
this whole thing like upgrade took
forever and this took forever anyway
that's done now we're going to go ahead
and copy the next command
so copy right-click and uh go and what
was this is a Lib Apache mod at WSGI
this so we can use WSGI it's honestly I
don't understand WSGI very much
we'll talk about this WSGI in a little
bit uh okay we didn't need to do that
that was already done
um but mata WSGI is basically the way
that we're going to be able to actually
use flask as a developmental framework
and so it's really helpful to us but it
can't there's a couple of bugs that come
with not really bugs but I don't know
I'm not really sure what else to call
them but they're pretty confusing and no
one's ever been able to give me a good
answer on mod WSGI so anyway we'll talk
about about those when we get there
though
but yeah it gets kind of confusing
anyway we've already enabled so now we
want to CD into 4ww which was created
when we installed right up here for
Apache and stuff so if you were going to
create say a PHP website that would have
been the same line that you ran and you
would store all your files there anyway
uh let's see D and devour www now and
just for the record we were in et Cie
SSH so let me go back there just in case
I'm sorry if you guys are you know pro
terminal users but for those of you who
are not if you start with a forward
slash write that go it basically treats
it like the beginning like the root of
the directory there's a lot of uses of
the word root so it can be confusing but
what if we were in ETCs SH and we so
when we did VAR w w we actually change
directory into the very beginning so
let's say you're on Windows and the very
very beginning is C colon slash right
and then you've got a bunch of
directories so that would be as if we
went all the way back to the root of C
colon slash but then what if you're in
ETCs SH and we instead said CD bar
without a forward slash ww-well it would
look for a directory called var within a
TC SSH and it will probably say it
doesn't exist
so keep that in mind those slashes are
very important so anyway going back to
the bar www
what do we do well first we're going to
make dira this flask app that makes a
directory called flask app easy enough
now we're going to CD into that flask
app directory now we're going to make
dur another flask app let me scroll down
a little bit here and again we're going
to CD into flask app so changing
directory now we're going to make two
directories in here we're going to make
first static and then we're also going
to make templates and now we're going to
sudo nano init PI and that basically is
going to open in it but PI it doesn't
exist so it's going to create it
temporarily at least so we create it
here we are and now we're going to put
some starting code into in it dot PI so
let's just copy this code copy
right-click and the code what it's doing
from flask import flasks or importing
flask we're specifying the name of our
flask basically our application for
flask and assigning it to this app bar
then we're saying the app root this is
how this is basically the URL to get to
this page that we're going to define
right here so this is the route to it so
basically the home page which we've
called the home page and it returns hi
there how you doing
so this is the code that's required to
get us there app root is required to be
just like a proof you can call this
function anything you want as long as
syntactically and grammatically correct
all right I guess I'm tactically is the
only word doesn't have to be
grammatically correct we call it home I
don't know anything you wanted anyway in
the return this normally can return
things like templates so HTML templates
with Jinja templating and some crazy
stuff which we'll get to but right now
she's just going to return a string of
hi there how you doing then finally if
name equals main we run the application
so hopefully we'll go to the the address
and it'll run in the basic series we
actually made the address an actual
domain I showed you guys how to do that
in this one I'm not really going to
focus too much on on the domain
if you really want to know check that
one out it's kind of a longer process so
we're going to actually just utilize the
IP address of our server that will get
you there you guys will be able to
actually look at this server so long as
it's up before I nuke it I'm not going
to always keep it up because I don't
think it's a good idea to have two
identical websites up anyways so anyway
but anyone can access it including you
you'll be able to access your own
website via the IP address and the
address bar anyway that's that control X
again why to save enter because that's
the same name done we've created our
init dot pi now we already ran the
update and upgrades so we don't need to
do that and now we're going to use sudo
apt-get to install pythons pip module
yes and that runs and then after that
we're going to install virtual
environment and this is kind of like a
way to have Python in literally a
virtual environment and that's where
we're actually install flask and run all
this stuff from flask it's kind of a
safer ish way to do things and just a
smarter way to keep you know your your
webserver separate from your your real
server so anyways pip install virtual
environment done now we're going to
create a virtual environment that we're
calling them and that's it now we can
activate that virtual environment if we
want and then to deactivate you just
type deactivate but first we want to pip
install flask in our virtual environment
well that's okay it's done and then now
we can do sudo python init dot pi so do
that real quick and as long as you don't
get any errors it's running but as we
can see it's actually only running
locally so whenever you see one 27001
that's a local IP address and basically
it's just your home so that's no good
for local you know web server but if you
were say your say you're following along
on a Raspberry Pi you could pull it or
any Linux based operating system or I
guess any operating system that you've
gotten this far on
you can visit one 2700 0.1 : 5,000 and
there will be your website but we're
going to continue moving on so we can
actually view this anywhere so ctrl C to
break that and then we're going to type
deactivate and now you can see that
we're not no longer in the virtual
environment because we don't have this
vem in front of our route there now what
we're going to do is we want to set up
the flask configuration file so that's
what this line does so copy paste here
we are and again we're just going to
copy and paste all of this code here no
sense in writing it yourself I don't
know anybody who would right-click
besides the original person who wrote
this I suppose virtual host port 84 HTTP
and this is the typical stuff server
name now for server name that's where
you're going to put the IP address to
your actual application so let me pull
this up here real quick I forget what
the IP was but I can get it really quick
you can also use ifconfig that will
figure that will give you your IP my IP
is the following so for server name if
you had a domain you would put your
domain name right there so on Python
program I met for example I have Python
programming dotnet also if you have say
for example you want to be accessed by a
Python program net and say wwwp I
thought program you'll just copy paste
and add WW here so I'll show you that in
a second but anyway so python program
net that's not what we want here for
this development server my IP is 104 236
44 192 put your IP there then if you
want you can add an email here it's like
an email for like if you have like a 500
error you'll see that email otherwise
that's it unless you change the
directory names where you stuff to the
flask app you don't need to change any
of this stuff here but if you did change
those names otherwise this isn't going
to work and again so like if you did
want to do wwl just show it really quick
copy come down paste and then literally
add the W double
you either I'm not really sure if it'll
work with an IP but I assume it would
we'll just leave it there just I'm
curious I suppose so control X yes to
save and we're done there now what we're
going to go ahead and do is sudo a two
so Apache to enable the site that looks
like it didn't do anything let me just
right-click copy that one more time
done it's enabled we'll run that reload
that it's asking us to reloads it now we
need to set up the WSGI file so we're
going to CD VAR w flask app so the
initial flask app sudo nano this flask
app WSGI and now we'll copy all of this
copy paste interesting this isn't can I
swear in the past this looks like a you
know treats it like it's a string anyway
delete what's there for now your secret
key and add your secret key
so just for now put like a little jumbly
of letters here okay just something
that's that control X yes to save and I
suppose before we go this is basically
this is the WSGI again w s-- g is is so
you can actually have flask as your
back-end WSGI is heck confusing to me
uh-huh so if you understand WSGI
congratulations na me
so anyway save yes it's like driving a
car right you a lot of stuff you can use
it and you don't need to know how an
internal combustion engine works to get
the utility out of your car you can do
some cool stuff with WSGI and of course
not knowing too much about it one of the
problems that arises is what i'll show
you guys later as far as every time we
make an edit we have to restart apache
you can make a script that reads every
time you make an edit and restarts
apache for you but that is the same
thing as just doing it yourself I'd
rather have something I don't know built
into the WSGI that works I had someone
suggested to me I'm right over my head
so anyway moving on so here now we'll
restart Apache
that restarts the web server you'll be
doing a lot of this for the reasons like
I just said and then now let's do I've
configured ready forgot the IP already
where's it here
so our internet address is this so now
you should be able to your web browser
and literally type that in so 104 236 44
192 enter and you should see hi there
how you doing
again you by the time you guys are
watching this tutorial
that won't be what's here on this IP I
might not even have this server anymore
eventually I'm going to nuke it and get
rid of it I'm just using it for the
tutorials but if you were around right
when I was making this you too could
visit this domain or this IP address and
you would see my website also just
curious so we can do the www I think the
problem is because of all the periods
but if you had a regular domain that
would work anyway uh that's it for this
series or this video the series is not
over I promise ya here you guys go
that's how to make a website done don't
forget to like anyway that's not it
that's it for this video if you guys
have any questions or comments please
feel free to leave them below otherwise
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time